I guess I should have expected that yeah
man guardians of the galaxy - spoilers
okay so we are we are oh man
but um yeah these uh man yeah so so
guarding to the galaxy to the dude man
there was so much that went on and it
was it was pretty stellar like it was it
was pretty solid super chat allows you
to donate and in the thing and your
comments go straight to the top like
your comments take take priority over
everybody else's so um yeah yondu was
amazing dude yondu went out like a hero
man that was that was so cool seeing
yondu go out that way it was it was sad
like it was it was really really sad um
but it was it was great to see it was it
was it was pretty solid to see that I
mean he basically sacrificed his life to
save Peter quill and it was pretty cool
it was it was pretty awesome good to see
ya I'm Mary Poppins yeah that was really
amazing that was okay so so the way that
he died they like rock hit like they
were they were stuck on the planet ego
like fighting ego we'll talk about Adam
yeah definitely
philip warden we'll talk about Adam um
so we ended up having they were fighting
on on ego because ego turns out to be
evil and this whole idea is to just like
spread his existence all throughout the
universe like basically conquer planets
that's why I say he's like the most you
know person ever when you go talked
about in planting seeds and planets over
the universe I felt this was an easter
egg for the celestial eggs do you think
it's potentially making way for a
fantastic for Galactus and phase four I
don't think were going to see Fantastic
Four twerk a lacus and phase four I
think it was really more of just an
easter egg to the nature of the
Celestials because that's how they
procreate they plant their eggs in
planets and then they turn around and
allow themselves to reform out of those
planets the planets die in the process
but they allow themselves to reform um
but yeah it's no fun so Sanchez it's lit
fan it is it was it was amazing
um you miss eternity okay so there's
there's a segment hold on so getting
back to it to yondu what ended up
happening with that is he ended up like
rocket only had like one jet pack and
like one suit and like one spacesuit
that would allow them to breathe in
space and so we put the suit on Peter
Coyle once you know and then took him
into space and you on duty to sacrifice
his life and died in space but it was
really cool yeah um do you feel ego
being a celestial worked no I do not
feel like it worked but anyway with
regards to the Celestials um so the
whole idea is yeah that's that's how
they procreate is they basically go in
and they just kind of plant themselves
in eggs I don't think we're going to see
Galactus I don't think we're going to
see any of that stuff I think it's just
kind of going to the idea of the of the
Celestials themselves that being said I
do not believe that ego working as being
a celestial works I don't really like
that idea
I think ego should has been like a
planet that gained sentience and some
world on one we literally have a guy
that travels dimensions and you know
fights guys named Dormammu who were like
evil space demons it makes sense you
know that that ego would just be like a
super evolved planet they give him
virtually anything so I didn't really
care for that it didn't take away from
the movie none at all you know I didn't
really care for that I mean the movie
was amazing and as we all found out
Drake Drax a destroyer has famously
large herds so it was interesting anyway
so the whole eternity thing eternity the
the whole idea with that was there was a
segment where ego basically allowed
star-lord to observe the universe to see
the universe and and star-lord basically
saw eternity so it was it was really
kind of cool to see that that little bit
but um I deserved more donations I
appreciated
Andrew Pearson I appreciate that but
yeah it's it's it's pretty awesome it
was it was really really enjoyable um
you I think Marwan got the rights back
to the Fantastic Four and all of his
characters no I don't think they did is
they did it'll be the best kept secret
he referred racks his nipples that they
make my nipples hurts
but yeah uh I don't know it's super chat
so I mean however it is a super chat
works I mean there should just be an
option because I assume you're on PC so
like I assume you're on a computer so
hold on second I'll tell you how it
works
all right um let me go to my channel and
then I should be able to go a few myself
live videos oh wow Patrick ward hey Rob
what direction do you think audience the
Galaxy three will take based on got
easily galaxy 2 that leads us directly
into our discussion about Adam warlock
Adam warlock is confirmed for the Marvel
Cinematic Universe guys he is in there
and it is it's cool to see why does it
not show it shows old videos it does a
show of new videos
well that's sex Adam warlock is in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe so the race of
gold people are over what they're called
like like Centurions or something like
that I can't remember but um at the very
end and one of the post-credits scenes
Aisha
who's basically like the Queen she has a
birthing chamber that looks like it
looks like Adam warlocks cocoon and she
basically says like like inside of it is
somebody named the sovereign there we go
inside of an is somebody named Adam and
it's going to be like a super powerful
person so Adam warlock is confirmed for
the Marvel Cinematic Universe I'm very
happy yeah the golden golden douchebags
yeah those folks were kind of dicks does
the plot make sense
when ego says he meets Peter to power
the terraforming that when new Peter has
his own power but when he go dies he
loses all that light can you explain
because ego is intrinsically tied to the
planet and so it's it's basically like
um Peter Quill's power is tied to the
progeny tied to being ego
basically tied to the fact that he goes
alive as long as ego stays alive Peter
Quill's connection to that power remains
when ego dies Peter's connection to that
power
way and so because of that you know he's
basically gone the Watchers the watchers
look kind of weird um they didn't look
how I would expect them to they looked
fine I mean you know but they they
didn't look a little bit weird it wasn't
really what I would expect it to be so
yeah the Watchers were in Guardians 3
and it was pretty pretty awesome uh it
doesn't okay it's not confirmed that
Stan Lee's a watcher he's just talking
to the watchers um which is cool
like weird is interesting uh you think
they were too tall and skinny did they
were pretty tall but yeah like like Stan
Lee was just kind of talking to them and
oh here's the other thing he references
other cameos like he references cameos
unlike spider-man and I think he
referenced a cameo in x-men I think but
no he references cameos in other movies
so that was really cool um yeah I don't
think Stan Lee is a watcher that would
be cool but not only you as a watcher it
would be interesting if he was like if
he was the one above all like that would
be pretty awesome
um Oh Caitlin What's Up Girl What's Up
Girl
I think it'd be interesting if he was
the one above all would you beg the
question why would the watchers just
walk away from the one above all when he
could just obliterate them it would be a
very intelligent thing but uh but yeah
um was I disappointed in any of the
characters I was a little bit
disappointed to mantis I felt like she
wasn't used as well as she could she was
just a plot device basically um let's
see Philip Orton thank you for her $2.00
does that mean Peter can't hold the
Infinity stones not anymore
uh he's the lost all of his powers so
he's just a regular person now so if you
were to pick up an infinity stone he
would die and so what that means is that
he he probably will not be able to wield
the infinity gold I have no idea
um but yeah like it is uh it's wild I
felt like mantis was a little bit
squadron she was basically a plot device
it was kind of disappointing I wish he
had had a little more of a role but then
the question would be like what role
would she have what role would she takes
us her doing spoilers oh wait
I have no idea what role she would take
yeah so uh so was Stanley the one above
all entity that's not confirmed he's
just there talking to the watchers so um
it really cracked me up how Drax was
brutal I mantis yeah he was just like
he's like you're very very attractive on
the inside like it's like you're very
ugly man do I think ego is a good
villain no I think egos like every
villain ever I think he's just you know
every villain has ever appeared in
encounter books is basically ego he's
not vanilla or in the movies he's like
these this marbles and hearing problem
Marvel cannot make compelling villains
so which is why I'm really really
worried about like Thanos and how those
villains gonna turn out so well that's
my concern is if we got like if we ended
up getting Drax to the store we end up
getting Galactus Galactus would be like
he probably died to be honest they'd
kill him
in that movie which would be ridiculous
so um yeah Ultron was kind of cool but
in the end he does he was just spouting
one-liners and fighting the bad you're
fighting the good guys so that was
really it Ronon was kind of cool I don't
think it was really great he was kind of
cool but yeah teen group looks also like
angsty teenage Groot
that does look kind of cool so um the
music was not annoying me I definitely
enjoyed the music so yeah I still watch
agents of shield as some of the best
story tellings I've ever had in the show
I can't wait for ghosts right over come
back though because I don't think it's
Ghost Rider was definitely better so um
anyway guys okay so those are the
spoilers basically there's really not
much not much more spoiler stuff besides
that that's really about as spoilery as
it gets but anyway guys I'm going to
bounce off here um this concludes our
videos for the day so tomorrow we do the
next guardians of the galaxy and then
after that we do oh by the way we do
gone into the galaxy and then we do the
free comic book day Captain America
video so that's going to be pretty
pretty wild but no there were a ton of
spoilers it was just kind of my opinions
and what was there and
thing so anyway guys I'm going to bounce
off here and I will catch you guys later
peace